the fight against the coronavirus
continues nevada's health care system is
still facing staff shortages we've seen
these shortages hit a variety of
different industries impacting vital
roles all across the board hector mejia
joining us now live in henderson sharing
how one local company is trying to solve
the problem hector good morning
good morning you know we don't get to
see this every day this morning we're at
community ambulance here a privately
owned ambulance company in henderson
we're finding out how they're working to
solve the shortages and uh what they're
doing to bring more workers on the force
this is glenn good morning to you good
morning thanks for having us so tell us
a little bit about you know what you
guys do here yeah so community aims
we're a private locally owned company
here in southern nevada
and we're we're in the midst of hosting
a job fair today so you guys see it
every day you guys are you know on the
front lines what sort of you know this
is an interesting question what's the
personality trait someone would would
need to have to to have this role
yeah so we're
our motto here at community ambulance is
heart and it's in our logo so heart
stands for honesty excellence
accountability respect and teamwork and
that's what we're looking for in
individuals that are interested in this
career gotcha so just show us a little
bit here you were giving us some
interesting information about this yeah
so we have a lot of incentives one of
our big incentives that we think
is important to the backs and and saving
everybody is our power load system
so our power load system it's a one-man
operation and so it's saving the backs
of our providers when they're going out
there why is this unique for you guys um
so we're the only private ambulance
company here in southern nevada that has
this in our entire 9-1-1 fleet
and again it's it's all about taking
care of our employees and so that's what
we're trying to do so as we talk about
these shortages can you just sort of
drive it home why is it so critical to
make sure we have the staffing that we
need
yeah you know obviously the height of
the pandemic we're seeing hospitals some
of their volumes at all some all-time
highs and so we're looking to
continually increase that staff and as
the city grows as we bring more events
to this exciting city we want to make
sure we have the staff to to provide the
safety that that's necessary to keep the
city open and going it's also
interesting you mentioned you guys are
offering up to a ten thousand dollar
bonus yes that sounds pretty crazy yeah
so you know we want to take care of our
employees and so our employees are all
going to see upwards of a 14 raise in
addition we're offering sign-on bonuses
up to ten thousand dollars if you join
the team
communityambulance.com click on careers
and hopefully you'll come out and see us
awesome thank you so much for your time
so yeah we'll be showing you another
part of the operations here again we are
in henderson we'll have those details
more about those details on the job fair
still ahead in the next half hour
reporting live hector mejia live local
now